oh my god that's so weird
subscribe hey I'm ready
I love slow-motion I've always always
dreamt of being able to play around with
the phantom camera that's the best the
most high speed camera on the market
when we're shooting our fallout videos
several years ago with Gavin from the
slow mo guys I got to you know have that
on set but I didn't really get to just
do whatever I wanted with it today my
dream is coming true my friend richard
ryan from full mag is coming to the
studio he has a whole day free and he
owns a phantom camera so we're gonna do
some crazy stuff okay what's special
about a phantom flex so the phantom flex
shoots 4k at just under a thousand
frames per second yeah if you guys
haven't seen his channel before he
basically just shoots guns really really
high frame rates my favorite is when you
shoot like the 50 Cal and you actually
see the bullet leaving the yeah that's I
mean it's so funny because I hated math
in school and now it's like oh I can
figure out like the perfect frame rate
for resolution for this shot on those
lines but I flex just makes it easy when
you're doing fun things like this
there's like this to 4k and we'll figure
it out around thousand frames per second
sounds good right we're the ones hanging
out yeah subconsciously what's happening
when you watch the slow motion is it's
making you smarter if our camera the red
is like a Porsche our Porsche can go 240
miles an hour to do 240 frames per
second Richard Ryan's bringing over a
race car that can go a thousand mile
slower it's pretty fast hardware wise
this is basically the equivalent of like
a scientific instrument and the reason
it's like a scientific instrument is
because letting you record the world and
a very high temporal resolution you have
spatial resolution your TV screen your
phone your computer screen these all
have spatial resolutions yeah what
you're seeing right now so you've heard
like 1080p that was 4k so temporal
resolution wise is how many frames per
second you're getting how many images
time is being broken down too as time
passes most cameras record 24 frames per
second 30 frames per sec so this cameras
temporal resolution at 4k 4 times higher
than what our red can do so what does
this mean but your brain can process at
a certain speed and the world is moving
in a certain speed around you you
10 seconds to think about something that
you otherwise would only have one second
to observe and think about it simulates
you being smarter and thinking faster
when you're watching something you can
see more detailed and see more temporal
detail you can see cause and effect more
clearly you have time to think about and
critically analyze structures of things
playing out in front of your eyes so you
otherwise might not be able to do when
things are playing at normal speed this
would do more damage probably because
it's more blunt blunt yeah at least
meaning cure it a little bit I think
it'll look good with that orange yeah
yeah that's what we're thinking is to
just like smash it with the plastic on
it okay cool you got it we want to smash
that like button all right we got our
ice here and we decide we're gonna burn
it with some gasoline but before we do
that we got to set up some cameras and
figure out the exact protocol or how
we're gonna do this so that we have the
maximum amount of safety well still also
delivering something cool
phantom Flex filming at 4k at 938 frames
per second we've got the FLIR camera
shooting at 30 frames per second which
is a thermal cam we're gonna see a
really big difference between the cold
blue ice and the hot red fire and of
course we got the ATD shooting at 60fps
now there's a smudge my god dude
technology is great but I'm just afraid
that like I'll hit it and I'll end up
just knocking it hit into the wall and
all of our cameras are pointed right
here do you have a fire here
[Music]
okay ready and 3 2 1
[Music]
this was left of the button
[Music]
looks great great man it felt so good to
smash ice and fire
felt like I was John snow and Danny yeah
how the fire and ice and smash and that
like button facilitate that for you hey
you know what I felt powerful and that's
why I said what I said would say for
this let's just focus on the the sword
itself give me like a flaming sword
that's sweet epic right looks like just
morphing between images we like the
sheets I felt like a laminar flow
was i the prince that was promised no I
want to see what it looks like when I
spin it fly no it's pretty cool stuff
you want to do one more goofy thing with
a slow-motion camera of course if you
spit it'll be way funnier way funnier
the more particles the more movement the
better flying out of your mouth well
that was cool I think we got some
footage great use of having Richard Ryan
by the studio today I think we got some
cool stuff
and it's like getting all this stuff is
super cool but I feel like we're missing
something I want to see what paint
drying at a thousand frames per second
looks like